I think we just caught a little bit of
lightning in the bottle Lana Del Rey's
definitely caught some fields cuz girls
got a new man
I can
[Music]
the 34 year old singer was spotted
enjoying a stroll around New York City's
Central Park on Monday with live PD star
Sean Stix Larkin et has learned that
Lana and Sean are in fact dating and the
Internet is obsessed with trying to find
out more details on Lana's new beau and
e t--'s got him Sean is on a andis live
PD where he provides insight about law
enforcement as an analyst for 3 hours
live every Friday and Saturday night but
Lana's boyfriend is not only a reality
star he's a real-life cop in Oklahoma
according to his Twitter bio Sean's job
title is full time Tulsa Popo that's the
the g-rated version of it sergeant
Larkin has been working with the Tulsa
Police Department's gang unit as part of
the Special Operations Division for over
21 years he's one tough dude back in
March he explained the dangerous story
behind his nickname sticks revealing the
captain of his unit gave him the name
after tackling a criminal without any
form of protection
he just started call me stick which was
short for F stick to the street as
people started to hear me called stick
from other officers and just the way the
Street lingo goes they thought my name
was Styx but don't expect Lana to be
calling him by that name
nobody in my private life calls me stick
and thanks to sticks his job and
seemingly CrossFit he's never afraid to
go shirtless you go wanna
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]